NEXT GUEST JOINING ME NOW
IS CONGRESSMAN ERIC SWOLE
WORLD DEMOCRAT OF CALIFORNIA
AND MEMBER OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WAS AT THE CENTER OF
SOME OF THESE REQUESTS
REPORTEDLY CONGRESSMAN. THANKS
FOR COMING BACK ON THE SHOW,
YOU
FOUND OUT THAT
THE TRUMP DOJ HAD SUBPOENAED
YOUR DATA,
ARE YOU ALLOWED TO TELL US
WHAT THEY GOT?
HOW MUCH OF AN INVASION OF
PRIVACY
IT WAS
WELL, IT WAS CERTAINLY AN
INVASION OF PRIVACY. I STILL
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH THEY GOT.
YOU KNOW, APPLE IS A LITTLE
BIT MORE TRANSPARENT
WITH ITS USERS THAN OTHER.
PROVIDERS. AND SO I RECEIVED
AN EMAIL FROM APPLE, IT LOOKED
LIKE A SPAM
EMAIL
THAT SAID, MY
ACCOUNT INFORMATION, BEEN
TURNED OVER TO DOJ. SO WE'RE
SEEKING THOSE ANSWERS
FROM DOJ
RIGHT NOW. BUT THE BIGGER
POINT HERE MEHDI
IS THAT PRESIDENTS IN OUR
COUNTRY? YOU KNOW THEY SET THE
TONE
FOR THE COUNTRY AND SO IF YOU
HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO'S
A BULLY
A PRESIDENT WHO HAS THIS PHONY
TOUGH-GUY PERSONA THAT'S GOING
TO TRICKLE DOWN. AND
SO DONALD TRUMP
THROUGH THE YEARS WE'VE SEEN
EVERY DAY AMERICANS START TO
REALLY TREAT OUR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS,
JUST AS HORRIBLY AS DONALD
TRUMP, WOULD TALK ABOUT THEM.
YOU'RE SEEING NBA PLAYERS
HAVING BOTTLES THROWN AT THEM
INDECENCY ON THE HOUSE FLOOR.
MY FEAR IS NOW THAT
MAYORS AND GOVERNORS, SEE THAT
DONALD TRUMP WAS DOING THIS TO
HIS POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
POSSIBLY THAT MAYBE THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO DO NOW
WHEN YOU DON'T LIKE
SOMEONE WHO COMES TO
CITY COUNCIL MEETING AND
SPEAKS AGAINST
YOU, YOU'RE GOING TO TURN
LEASH THE LOCAL SHERIFF
ON THEM. THAT'S THE REAL
SERIOUS PLAYERS THAT THE
TRICKLE-DOWN EFFECT
YEAH, TRUMPISM WITHOUT TRUMP.
CONGRESSMAN, THE INVESTIGATION
IS CLOSED AND NO CONNECTION
WAS FOUND BETWEEN YOUR
COMMITTEE AND THOSE ALLEGED
LEAKS.
NOW, FORMER TRUMP
AG'S, BILL BAR AND JEFF
SESSIONS
HAVE BOTH DENIED, KNOWLEDGE
OF THE SUBPOENAS AS HAS
THEIR DEPUTY ROD ROSENSTEIN.
HOW CAN THAT BE POSSIBLE THAT
NONE OF THEM KNEW
IT'S NOT POSSIBLE, I'M EDDIE
AND WE JUST SENT A LETTER
TO DOJ FROM
THE HOUSE, JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
LAYING OUT HOW WE KNOW IT'S
NOT POSSIBLE BECAUSE
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND A
SITUATION LIKE THIS TO HAVE
THEIR DATA
SURVEILLED. THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S, THE ATTORNEYS
GENERAL. IN THIS
INSTANCE WOULD HAVE TO KNOW
AND I JUST DON'T BELIEVE THAT
IT WAS INCOMPETENCE AND IT
DIDN'T MAKE ITS WAY TO THEM.
THEY KNOW THAT DONALD TRUMP
ROUTINELY WAS CALLING ADAM
SCHIFF, A LEAK, OR DONALD
TRUMP
ROUTINELY.
ATTACKING ME ON TWITTER AND WE
HAPPEN TO BE THE ONLY TWO ON
THE COMMITTEE. IT LOOKS LIKE
SO FAR WHO WERE TARGETED. SO
YEAH, I JUST DON'T BUY IT
AND SO, I GUESS,
I'M PUTTING THE BURDEN ON THEM
TO PROVE TO ME THAT THEY
DID NOT KNOW.
I MEAN, THE THING IS,
LUCKILY FOR BAR AND SESSIONS,
THEY HAVE GREAT REPUTATIONS
FOR HONESTY SO THEY'LL GET
THROUGH THIS. I THINK
CONGRESSMAN'S RIGHT ON THE ONE
HAND, IT LOOKS A LOT LIKE
IT LOOKS A LOT LIKE,
THE TRUMP JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
MAY HAVE CROSSED SOME PRETTY
MAJOR LINES TO TRY AND FERRET
OUT. WHATEVER LEAKS THEY WERE
SEARCHING FOR ON THE OTHER
HAND. I HAVE TO POINT OUT, DO
YOUR A DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN,
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
WAS ALSO VERY AGGRESSIVE IN
SURVEILLING JOURNALISTS FROM
THE AP, FOR EXAMPLE, FROM
FOX NEWS, PHONE RECORDS
ETC.
THOSE
AMONG MANY OTHERS AND JOHN
BRENNAN,
EVEN HAD TO APOLOGIZE AFTER
THE CIA, SURVEILLED
SENATE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
STAFFERS
LINES TO CROSS IN THIS
COUNTRY? I MEAN, OBAMA DIDN'T
SET
GREAT PRECEDENT HERE I'M SORRY
TO SAY
MAYBE I THINK THAT'S A GOOD
POINT
EXCEPT I WOULD DISTINGUISH THE
TWO
IN OBAMA'S DOJ. DOING THAT WAS
WRONG.
HOWEVER
I DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S
EVIDENCE THAT
THE DOJ UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS DOING IT
TO BE VINDICTIVE.
DEVORE. THAT IT WAS
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED. IT WAS
NOT A SMEAR AND CLEAR
EFFORT.
WE'RE HERE. WE'RE STILL
LEARNING EXACTLY WHAT WAS
GOING ON,
BUT IT SURE SMELLS LIKE A
SMEARING CLEAR.
AFTER
NO, IT'S A FAIR DISTINCTION
AGREE THAT IT'S WRONG WHETHER
IT'S DONE BY A DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENT, OR REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT. WE DO NEED TO REIN
IN
SURVEILLANCE
THE SURVEILLANCE STATE IN THIS
COUNTRY AND KEEP THE
DOJ WITHIN BOUNDS WEATHER.
AS YOU SAY, WHETHER IT'S
BARACK OBAMA, DONALD TRUMP OR
JOE BIDEN
IS PRESENT AND I HOPE YOU AND
YOUR COLLEAGUES ARE DOING THAT
ON THE COMMITTEE, YOU CREATED
A FLAP YESTERDAY. CONGRESSMAN,
WHEN YOU REVEAL THAT US
CAPITOL POLICE OFFICER,
MICHAEL FUN AND HAD APPARENTLY
BEEN SNUBBED
WHEN TRYING TO APPROACH
JANUARY 6TH MINIMIZING
CONGRESSMAN
HAVE A LISTEN TO WHAT FAN ON
SAID TODAY.
I SAW HIM STANDING OUTSIDE
OF AN ELEVATOR
BAY ONCE HE GOT ON THE
ELEVATOR
MYSELF AND OFFICER DUNN.
DUNN ACCOMPANIED HIM ON THE
ELEVATOR
AND I SIMPLY
GREETED HIM
EXTENDED MY HAND.
HE STARED AT ME,
REFUSED TO SHAKE MY HAND. HE
SAID THAT HE DIDN'T KNOW WHO I
WAS.
I INTRODUCED MYSELF. I SAID
MY NAME IS ALTER MICHAEL FOR
NOON. I'M A DC POLICE OFFICER
AND I FOUGHT TO DEFEND THE
CAPITAL ON JANUARY 6TH.
AND I EXPLAINED TO HIM SOME
OF THE
INJURIES THAT I SUFFERED AS A
RESULT OF THAT,
HE JUST STARED AT ME,
TURNED AWAY.
PULLED OUT HIS CELL PHONE
LOOKS LIKE HE WAS TRYING TO
RECORD
THE INTERACTION,
WE DIDN'T SPEAK.
AND AS SOON AS THE ELEVATOR
BAY DOORS OPEN,
HE REIGN.
CONGRESSMAN, IS IT JUST ME
OR DID DEMOCRATS GET
BEATEN UP AND BEAT THEMSELVES
UP OVER DEFUNDING?
THE POLICE WHILE
REPUBLICANS ARE REFUSING TO
SHAKE THE HAND OF
CAPITOL POLICE HEROES, VOTING
TO BLOCK THEM FROM GETTING A
MEDAL.
HOW IS IT THAT YOUR BODY GETS
SO EASILY HAMMERED ON
POLICE ISSUES AND THEY GET
AWAY WITH THAT?
BECAUSE WE DON'T PUNCH BACK
HARD ENOUGH AND I'M PUNCHING
BACK IS A BROTHER TO TWO
POLICE OFFICERS.
IT'S EASY TO SAY EVERY OTHER
NOVEMBER THAT YOU BACKED THE
BLUE.
BUT WHEN THE RUBBER YOU KNOW
MET THE ROAD AND
THE BLUE PUT THEIR LIVES
IN FRONT OF OURS SO THAT WE
COULD FLEE AND GO TO A
SECURE LOCATION.
WE'RE REALLY SEEING WHO IS
STANDING UP FOR THE HEROES IN
THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
WE'RE FINDING OUT THAT
TO HONOR DONALD TRUMP. YOU
HAVE TO DISHONOR THE
POLICE AND THAT'S WRONG.
AND I HOPE
VOTERS SEE THAT
IT'S BEEN PHONY.
EVERY ELECTION
BEFORE
NOW AND WE ARE SEEING THEIR
TRUE COLORS. AND THEIR TRUE
COLORS ARE NOT BLUE.
I HAVE TO ASK ABOUT THE
LAWSUIT. YOU FINALLY SERVE.
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN MO
BROOKS WITH ALLEGING. HE
HELPED IN SIGHT, THE
JANUARY 6 RIOT.
CONGRESSMAN BROOKS. HIS WIFE
IS REPORTEDLY. SWORN OUT A
WARRANT FOR THE MAN WHO SERVED
OR THEIR HOME AS FAR AS YOU
KNOW. DID HE DO IT LAWFULLY?
DO YOU THINK THE PURPLE, YOU
KNOW, FOR THE PURPOSES OF
SERVING THE LAWSUIT,
EVERYTHING WAS DONE
APPROPRIATELY BY YOU AND YOUR
LEGAL
TEAM.
YEAH, MY LEGAL TEAM TELLS ME.
IT WAS DONE APPROPRIATELY
MEDI, BUT TAKE A STEP
BACK.
WHY WAS IT SO HARD TO
SERVE A MEMBER OF CONGRESS?
WHY WAS HE DUCKING AND DODGING
DODGING SERVICE FOR SO LONG?
YOU KNOW, HE BENEFITED FROM
THE CAPITAL BEING LOCKED DOWN
AND VISITORS WEREN'T ABLE TO
COME
AND SERVE HIM THERE. BUT, FOR
OVER A MONTH AND A HALF, HE
REFUSED TO BE SERVED WHERE I
COME FROM THAT'S CALLED
CONSCIOUSNESS OF GUILT.
WELL, HE OBVIOUSLY
DENIES ANY ROLE IN IT, EVEN
THOUGH HE IS ON TAPE,
SAYING SOME PRETTY AWFUL
THINGS.
PRETTY EASY THINGS THAT SOUND
PRETTY INCITING,
BUT WE'LL HAVE TO SEE WHERE
YOUR
LAWSUIT GOES
THANK YOU SO
UCCOH NGFORER SSYOMAURN.  E